there's no like how to eat instructions
like you know with soup dumplings
there's a right way to eat soup
dumplings in the wrong way
no you have a toy inside be careful I
didn't know that can drugs are banned in
the US but I'm curious to find out why I
heard that kids die from eating them and
that might be why they're leaks that's
the surprise I'm pretty sure that the US
had a version of the kinder egg called
the Wonder ball that a bunch of kids
like choked on or something I'm afraid
I'm going to get arrested
yeah for just holding these I didn't
expect it to be like whoops
getting a good sound out of this thing
you can use this as a percussion
instrument I'll go for that fortune
cookie approach right pretty smashing
it's like hollow it's like a little
minion I don't even know how to open
this nonetheless like died from it
what are you are what are you doing I
think you just eat the entire home all
right how are you gonna die from this
though like what kind of kid is gonna
swallow hmm really bad chocolates good
oh it's a frog Oh see you can't go maybe
these are banned because they're a lot
of fun hey did you choke on your kinder
egg oh that's good I think the pop of
this little yellow egg was the best part
of the whole process banning this toy is
American you should be able to choke on
a little object if you want to choke
okay what I believe just my beliefs